عزيزه ابدا لي طالبه جامعيه تدرس في كليه
الطب منعتها طالبان من الذهاب الى الجامعه
تقول ان طموحاتها قد ذهبت ادراج الرياح
كما ذهب الطموحات زميلاتها
ولكن ط
البان عدنان
فوق الصف السادس الابتدائي امام الفتيات
الافغانيات لنحو 16 شهرا ما اثار انتقادات
داخليه لم تؤدي الى نتائج ملموسه
ليس لدينا خيار اخر لمواصله الدراسه داخل
البلاد فاذا اردنا الدراسه علينا المغادره
للخارج
[موسيقى]
اثار ادانات دوليه متعدده وضغوطا على حركه
طالبان للتراجع عنه
طالبان تبرر قرارها بانها تنشغل
فيما الفتيات الافغانيات غير مقتنعات بهذه
التمريرات لان طالبان على سده الحكم منظر
نحو 16 شهرا وكان يجب عليها ان تتغلب على
هذه المشاكل ايا كانت عبدو نادر العربيه
كابول